around here we do not follow a public school calendar
so even though our public schools are off this week
we are not gonna take off Thursday and Friday
and just have a normal beginning of the week
I think it's an important time to remind you
that you get to homeschool however you want
during the holiday you can take time off
you can continue homeschooling like normal
you can ditch your curriculum and do a holiday themed unit study
you can cut back on formal lessons to make time for seasonal activity
you are going to be bombarded with a lot of things and ideas this holiday season
but you get to choose what works and what is fulfilling to your family